ja Erdogan geriert sich als
internationaler Spieler und er kann es
auch in den nächsten fünf Jahren tun
wenn die Zahlen sich bestätigen wir
fragen nach bei der Kollegin Katharina
Willinger in Ankara Frau Willinger hat
sich die Tendenz der Zahlen jetzt
verstet
sie müssen
Fragen noch mal ich versuche es noch mal
wir hören auch dass es sehr laut ist bei
ihnen sind die Zahlen in Ankara haben
sich die Zahlen für Erdogan bestätigt in
den letzten Stunden
also ich habe jetzt verstanden haben
sich die Zahlen bestätigt ich gehe jetzt
mal darauf ein es gibt immer noch kein
Endergebnis es ist so dass die
Nachrichtenagenturen die die Zahlen ja
weitergeben vom hohen Wahlrat das ist
die Anadolu agency die ist staatlich und
die Anker Nachrichtenagentur die steht
der Opposition
Opposition da die veröffentlichen seit
etwa 200 Stunden zahlen und da liegt
Erdogan mit etwa 4% Punkten vorne auch
jetzt noch es ist noch nicht völlig
ausgezählt der hohe Wahlrat hat auch
noch nicht offiziell Stellung genommen
das erwarten wir vielleicht den einen
bis anderthalb Stunden Erdogan selbst
hat sich ja schon um etwa 19:30 Uhr
deutscher Zeit zum Wahlsieger erklärt in
Istanbul vor einem großen Publikum er
hat sich bedankt bei seiner Wählerschaft
für das Vertrauen dass man ihn wieder
entgegengebracht hat und er hat auch
gegen die Opposition Gewitter
Herausforderer der ist vor etwa 15
Minuten aufgetreten vor den Kameras hier
im
thp-gebäude in Ankara und auch gesagt er
wird weiter kämpfen was die Zukunft
angeht er möchte dass seine Wählerinnen
und Wähler mit erhobenem Haupt aus
dieser Wahl rausgehen und er machen sich
große Sorgen um die Zukunft der Türkei
unter Erdogan Frau Willinger was glauben
Sie was wird jetzt auf die Türkei
zukommen was wird vor allem auf die
laizistischen Menschen in der Türkei
zukommen wird die Lage wenn man zum
Beispiel an die das Justizsystem denkt
noch schwieriger werden unter Erdogan in
den nächsten fünf Jahren
das ist die große Befürchtung die viele
im Land haben dass es weitere
Einschnitte gibt zunächst einmal dass
Erdogan eben auch nicht versöhnlich auf
den Teil der Bevölkerung zugehen wird
der ihn ja abwählen wollte und sie haben
es angesprochen Thema Rechtsstaat das
ist eine große Baustelle seit vielen
Jahren und da fürchten viele Beobachter
noch weitere Einschnitte auch beim Thema
Frauenrechte und in seiner Rede vor etwa
anderthalb Stunden in Istanbul da hat er
ja auch sofort wieder gezeigt wie ähm
seine Einstellung ist hinsichtlich bzw
hinsichtlich Pendant der Rechte der
lgbti Community beispielsweise da hat er
gegen sie gewettert auch gegen die
Opposition die Familie sei heilig also
das ist auch ein eine eine Zeichen dafür
dass er an die Frauenrechte weiter daran
will und aus der Istanbul Konvention aus
der man ja ausgetreten ist dass man da
vielleicht noch einen Schritt zurück
macht dass die große Befürchtung und was
wir immer wieder im Land hören von sehr
vielen liberale eingestellt aber auch
jungen Türkinnen und Türken im Land
Kurdinnen und Kurden im Land ist dass
sie keine Hoffnung haben dass sich in
den nächsten Jahren etwas verbessert das
nicht nur die wirtschaftliche Lage
sondern eben auch die gesellschaftliche
Polarisierung immer größer wird und das
auch nicht wenige mit dem Gedanken
spielen das Land zu verlassen jetzt
hinter mir man hört vielleicht äh da
sind die Leute die das ganz anders sehen
das sind die Fans die Anhänger Erdogans
und die feiern ihren Sieg heute Nacht